we are airborne drones have gone
mainstream even Modern Family character
Phil Dunphy has won they're not getting
high they're making a movie without me
he's borrowed it from his real estate
company to spy on his son real estate is
one area where real-life drone use is
widespread groans shoot video of
properties neighborhoods and even home
interiors they're capturing top surfers
hanging ten on Hawaii's North Shore the
filmmaker of a Gettysburg documentary
boasted about the technology it's
mounted with a gyro-stabilized hi-def
camera it can shoot from a few feet off
the ground to 400 feet in the air
they're beautiful shots that also may be
illegal the FAA does not permit drone
flights for commercial purposes
you cannot just acquire one of these
vehicles and launch it into the airspace
that that's not how it works but you can
well I mean that is how it works I'm
saying that the regulation needs to say
that we went shopping at a drone
dealership in Maryland to see how easy
it is to get one for the Phantom -
you're gonna go into the 800 to a
thousand range and for the one with the
camera as you see here that'll be closer
to the 1,500 to 2,000 range can we try
it out
sure
all right we have lift-off technician
Doug Bennett says the camera equipped
DJI phantom 2 is flying off the shelves
and the sales are legal how the drones
are used is someone else's problem is
there anything in here that's gonna show
me what the FAA says I can and can't do
with this thing at the moment actually
this box will not tell you about the FAA
while the FAA is struggling to write new
guidelines
maziq ro is worried about crashes in
this surf video you can see a chopper in
the drones airspace what's the worst
case the drone could bring down the
helicopter so far the FAA hasn't done
much to enforce its commercial use ban
it says some 17 notices ordering people
to stop using drones but issued just one
fine last month the FAA did order Lake
made beer to stand down after an online
video pitched beer delivery via drone
two ice fishermen in Minnesota